hi my name is sonia this is my son
raymond today i'm here to cook one of my
favorite cuban dishes picadillo rae is
going to leave the kitchen while i cook
when he comes back he's not going to
have one dish he's going to have three
identical dishes in front of him then he
will have to pick which one i made let's
hope he picks rye pressure's on
out
first up we're gonna make our rice i
have my rinsed rice i like using the
rice cooker only because i can be
starting the other dish at the same time
and our water's in a pinch of salt and i
like to put a little bit of oil it's
about two cups here so it's going to
take anywhere about 15-20 minutes and
now we're going to put this aside and
we're going to start my picadillo we're
going to start with our ground beef this
is a scaled-down version of what i cook
at home
i always like to make just a little
extra in case you have that extra guest
coming
or you want to save it for your next day
to make other dishes that you can make
with the picadillo we can make some
empanadas you can also make some very
famous papatayena then we're going to go
ahead and add some onions
and also bell peppers
cuban style pinch of salt
just a tad of pepper not too much
a little bit of oregano
the majority of the cuban dishes are not
spicy we just like to put in enough
flavors but not spicy
so now we're going to go ahead and add
our garlic a little bit of the tomato
paste and tomato sauce a lot of people
don't like the olives but it is a
tradition i almost forgot raisins this
just gives it that little sweet kick
lastly i'm adding the sazon there are
different kinds of sasonas out there
this one has a little extra ingredient
to help you color the meat a little bit
as well from start to finish it takes
anywhere from about
25 minutes to half an hour it's a
favorite dish it's something that's
quick and easy my grandmother arrest her
so it was one of her favorite dishes so
that's
one of the main reasons we we take pride
in doing this one in our house because
she was the one that taught us how to
cook this everything looks wonderful
we're just going to top it off and we're
going to start our patanitos maduro
let's see we're going to pick out the
most ripe
i'm just going to peel here
as you can see they're very right we're
going to be cutting it at a long angle
when you get them at the markets they
come anywhere from hunter green to as
you see here when they turn very brown
those are the most ripe
i'm going to slide them right in be very
very careful of course you know your oil
is extremely extremely hot you just want
to cook them till they get just a little
bit brown on the sides less than a
minute on each side
loving my parents their cooking the love
that they put into the food it was just
uh you know something wonderful if i
were my son's shoes and my mom were
cooking absolutely i would know in a
heartbeat which one would be hers so we
have our three dishes here let's plate
up
and normally we're like to put a little
bit more but because raymond has to
taste two other dishes we're gonna just
give him a little taste here
we'll give him three because i know he
likes them
and here's our dish picadillo white rice
and sweet plantains hopefully he picks
mine hi my name is raymond royero jr i
am sonia sun her favorite son her only
son but still her favorite i hope i get
it right because i wouldn't be able to
live it down with myself if i don't get
it right let's just put this into
perspective okay i didn't come in my car
so if i get this wrong i'm probably
gonna sit in the trunk if you guys and
girls are watching pray for me
time to eat
let's eat
[Music]
number one it looks pretty good if
you're cuban you don't like this
flavor is good
the platanos tastes familiar but it
tastes different at the same time
the rice though
i don't know that really doesn't taste
like my mom's rice i just don't know the
seasoning on the picadillo is a lot
different than how my mother really
makes it you never know once i try the
other plates i will be sure damn this
looks really good this one actually has
raisins in it i like it uh the ones that
have raisins in it
if you don't like raisins in your freak
idea you should really try it it's so
good
rico the rice isn't bad the picadillo is
just amazing the seasoning isn't as
thick as the first plate i mean it's
really balanced it's not too salty the
platanos they look amazing it's not too
burnt though i kind of like it a little
dark but this is really nice the rice is
not bad either i'm a big rice guy i like
rice so number two
was really good
number one what's good number three is
it meant to be let's see well this looks
a lot different
the platanos are darker piglet looks
good oh my god it has potatoes and it
actually doesn't have olives
it's good but it's just
the seasoning is just a little bit too
much on this one the bladder nose are
good i love that there's potatoes i love
potatoes it helps balance out the food
it helps balance out the flavor out of
these three dishes
i'm stuck between one and two because
visually they're both similar to my
mom's but
i know how my mom cooks it's gotta be
number two and if i'm wrong this might
be the last time all of you see me
mom i picked number two the plantains
were made exactly where you make them
you don't put them too dark you don't
put it too light but i could be wrong
but please tell me if i got it right or
wrong
well
no this one oh no way
it's this one oh thank god
i'm sweating right here i am i'm oh
please get this right
you got it right thank god
so i can sit next to you on the right
home
yeah
i got it right
so all those years of eating with her it
worked for something so eat your food
that your mom gives you
look she only has to deal with me the
rest of her life so this is just one
stage of me surviving
do
you